hi my name is reto Meier and I'm the
tech lead for Google's Android developer
relations team this is the first in a
series of dev bytes created to help you
improve the battery efficiency of your
apps by changing the way you handle your
data transfers the mobile cell radio is
one of the biggest sources of battery
drain on modern smartphones so making
sure transfers use it efficiently can
make a dramatic difference to your apps
impact on the battery life now on the
surface this seems like a pretty simple
challenge if the cell radio drains the
battery just transfer as little data as
possible as infrequently as possible now
that's a good start but we want to
balance that with providing a great user
experience one with the data your users
need is available as soon as they need
it without them ever needing to hit
refresh now that requires understanding
how to optimize the timing of your data
transfers and that means understanding
the cell state machine now in order to
conserve power the cell radio isn't kept
on permanently in fact it goes through a
series of state transitions in order to
compromise between low latency data
transfers and minimizing the impact on
battery life it begins over here on
standby mode we're restoring minimal
power until an app initiates a data
transfer at this point it transitions to
full power mode a process that takes
around two seconds before performing the
transfer now rather than dropping back
to standby immediately after the
transfer is completed the radio will
remain in full power mode for a set tail
time just in case further transfers are
initiated within that window this
happens because dropping to a low-power
state reintroduces this powerup latency
not only that the transitioning between
states in and of itself is a significant
power drain now if nothing happens
during the five to ten second tail time
the radio drops to this intermediate
low-power state that uses less battery
than full power but has a lower startup
latency than standby if a new transfer
is initiated it will be promoted back to
full power mode and if nothing happens
for another thirty Seconds to a minute
it'll drop back to standby the exact
latencies Intel times vary between
carries or even within carriers
depending on where they are as carriers
try to balance low latency with longer
battery life based on things like cell
congestion
and typical prevailing network
conditions to understand how this might
affect your app design choices you start
with this simple equation then take the
square root of the sum of the latency
and idle times between each state and
then throw all of that out because it
really doesn't require any math to do
and it doesn't even matter what the
specific latency or tail times are for
any users of your app the solution comes
down to what I like to call the cookie
droid conundrum when scheduling
downloads do you transfer as much as you
can as infrequently as possible
minimizing the number of transfers at
the expense of bandwidth or do you take
the opposite approach transferring as
little as possible performing transfers
more frequently well on the surface the
little little cookie model appears sound
less data transferred means less
bandwidth and less time spent with the
radio active to transfer our data and
because we're downloading what we need
on demand we never download and process
more than we need
unfortunately this results in a heavily
fragmented use of the cell radio from
our knowledge of the cell radio state
machine we know that every time we
perform a data transfer the radio stays
active for at least 5 seconds of tail
time at full power followed by anywhere
from 10 to 60 seconds at lower power
before it finally returns to standby
that means every time you initiate a
transfer you're powering the cell
already up for at least 20 seconds now
we look at this more closely you can see
how an app like this one whose radio use
is indicated here can drain the battery
without transferring very much data each
of these small Peaks represents
something like analytics data being sent
back to the server every 15 seconds
while the larger Peaks they represent
intermittent transfers based on user
interaction maybe clicking on a news
article or looking at a restaurant
listing now beneath that we can see how
this affects the radio state machine
with blue showing active transfer times
the red indicating the radio remaining
in full power mode yellow showing lower
power mode and the gaps between showing
us where the radio is idle now we can
see straight away that there are no gaps
meaning that while this app is running
it's keeping the cell radio powered on
continuously in fact the regular updates
are alone
are enough to prevent the radio from
ever returning to an idle state that
shows us that the big cookie model is a
far better approach to coordinating our
data transfers in this example I've
bundled all of the repeating transfers
together and the intermittent transfers
have been largely replaced with
aggressive prefetching now obviously you
usually can't entirely predict what data
users might need nor can you ignore
either client or server side changes
that need to be synchronized but you can
aim to minimize the number of Radio
state transitions through a combination
of aggressive prefetching in addition to
batching and queuing any transfers that
aren't time critical and bundling these
with user initiated time critical
transfers or those initiated from the
server the result is a significant
improvement in the amount of battery
drain your app is responsible for in
comparison to the previous on-demand
approach the radio is now idle nearly
2/3 of the time even the active radio
percentage has dropped significantly
thanks to an improved download
efficiency as a result of transmitting
more data in each shot so taking the
cell radio into account you can minimize
the battery impact associated with your
apps data transfers by transferring as
little data as possible as infrequently
as possible defragment your network
access by prefetching batching and
bundling your transfers and a limit
client eliminate clients initiated
updates and pooling as much as possible
most important thing to remember is that
every time you transfer data no matter
how small the radio is powered up for
nearly half a minute
so every decision you make should be
based on minimizing the number of times
that this happens I dive into each of
these topics in more detail and other
videos in the efficient data transfer
series of devbytes including looking at
ways you can analyze your own data
transfer profile and how to implement
some of these best practices using
simple code patterns as well as
implementing sync adapters and Google
Cloud messaging solutions
you